hi guys I'm Gregory I'm Jerry Jonny
Gregory on Anjaani Gregory we're gonna
watch from one of the best channels of
all time a channel called bad lip
reading oh boy inauguration day you know
I do as you guys know the real rejects
you can tell from the title we are
primarily a political Channel yeah so
this was recommended to us we were like
absolutely we have said from the get-go
100% rum 100% yeah yeah Trump Trump's
all yeah I say he's the best see I got a
tattoo on my back I could show you guys
he does he does have a tattoo of Donald
Trump's face mm-hmm and Donald Trump's
penis on his back I don't have the exact
penis not running is it sliding of
golden penis that also has a shark fin
and like a unicorn horn into the Sun
that's great but give it all away before
I show it think well no no there's the
part that goes down your lower back
which that's just that's between you and
you're gonna watch this okay oh yeah
there's gonna be plenty buff so
important [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
compact oh [ __ ] do you know what you
just said
will you carry I'm always like oh yeah
sure you're certainly not gonna make a
nice company can't we now surgeon will
be able be a funny leader can't you ha
ha ha ha important you want to be me I'm
good big you what is it
looks like we have a problem yeah give
it to me okay we're going to squeeze it
hot looking are you wearing a big boy
shirt yeah probably never really game
[Applause]
bar you got me again boy kissing woman
that is here I like you nail polish but
not too much
listen I like you for the heat ha ha old
like two feet after me
I make grease pellets in my sweat
I make crease pellets in my sweat I was
disappointed they didn't find the
continent of Atlantis yet I was
disappointed they didn't find the
continent of Atlantis unit oh the new
kid smells like falafel and wants to
shave my mustache the new kids don't
like falafel and wants to shave my
mustache so did aunt Belinda
so did aunt Belinda
rusted anything so accusing is present
ah you're talking hand and repeat after
me
I gotta get a grip you saw me squat go
to get a group you saw miss what you
think I won't flame three eggs at you
you think I will fling three years at
you the goldfish of preteens never had a
chance
the goldfish of preteens never hit a
chick I personally have period a cage
fight it personally appeals to the cage
fight and I choose an awful lot of
cheese because it should also notice
cheese and I started in like a student
Mother's Day together we will build a
bar in rural Connecticut and we will
make it a farm with a nanny and we will
make it upon a brown lady we will make
it a park that has stuff in it and extra
good leather oh I wanna make a fast day
a greater day then comes a grand lady
the next party
no music just me you know that was later
the hamburger and milk does not fish no
fun yay
I'm also gonna need you to scream my
bunny yes good disguise the box you know
okay just remember who brought you here
thank you my friend
thank you uh weird you know you might
want to clean my car after this I mean I
really wouldn't call it yours right cuz
you gotta go back to a Jetta pretty
dorky we still know how to drive guy
doing up I don't do it well I got a big
truck I'm gonna figure out a way to
spare you stuff better burying your junk
already that's my car the kids made me a
shiv and I mean I'm not afraid to use it
I will get laid it's pretty good every
day I worry all day Wow sweetie these
guys are brilliant yeah they really they
really do look like this and from that
stuff I wonder how they actually uh I
wonder how they film it I mean I don't
have a habit how they do this you know
like is it like a whole crew people I'm
thinking about like the people like
sitting in a staff like like what do
they do these watch it with the video
like them the footage muted that's what
I want you were like our daughter
language you know because it didn't take
a whole inauguration so they're going
through footage here foot is there and
almost wondering to fill in the blanks
you know yeah I almost wonder if they
just put it on you and then just try to
talk along with it until yeah like
they're saying something yeah I would be
very curious Trump's president now bland
yes reverie sure I'm more than positive
like they were like a few hundred women
marching across the world 300 like 600
women I think 600 people 600 people
marching all across America it's really
not that many when you think about how
many people live in a
hundred and a good-sized move easy yeah
right John was at the woman's March
because I'm a woman for women to have
freedom you know - it's really for
everybody in birth control and have
abortions and [ __ ] yeah yeah so I always
kill as many before fighting for
practically Florida babies as possible
really everyone should get one my job is
to piss off both Republicans and
Democrats an arc II totally portions
love them yeah my favorite thing and do
we got the hottest first lady you had
ever had the hottest first lady we've
ever had she's the only first lady I
think that has posed for nude photograph
that's amazing mm-hmm yeah I well it is
in a way I mean think about it out of 45
first ladies we've had how many of them
can you say guys can jerk off to from
online book you know and now we don't
have one that we can masturbate to not
amazing it's a step forward for your say
nothing wrong with that it's not there's
there is nothing wrong with that if
women want to be able to [ __ ] wherever
they want while staying on the pill I
think that we can jerk off to the first
lady
right guys yeah look you guys agree on
that for her what is the bat first she
looks so happy she looks so happy if she
looks ridiculous I'll ever be happy
again once this whole experience is over
I think we should all be more like first
lady with a la nieta Melania Trump we
should all be like First Lady Melania
Trump just repress everything that you
feel shame guilt embarrassment bottle it
all up and just do any is wherever you
can't make money that's the American Way
now people I've always wanted it to like
rebrand the Statue of Liberty was just a
giant sign it says I got mine hey yeah
hey hey hey hey millions all right Ian I
got the best sides it's going to be huge
you're going to be able to read it from
Russia it's the best tremendous Trump
like when he was speaking at the CIA
oh yeah totally he brought up a great
fact that people were a lying about none
about how many people were not attending
was an original factor an alternative
fact I like alternative effects a lot
better they have like a lot more passion
stuff no dude that was a Kellyanne
Conway said that
good call it was it was her wait was it
was that other guy no she said it on a
on an internet fax yeah there you go pay
attention to your Paul - yeah yeah yeah
you good woman March six hundred people
one of those six other people's meaning
now the other guy yeah gotta [ __ ] with
his name but he was the one who said
like they don't count numbers numbers
don't matter and by far that was a large
shrub the largest is deadness anyone's
ever been ever to know Gary
oh my god I read the phoniest wrote of
this today like so the Washington Post
or some something put up an art of
article called like the true account of
Donald Trump's inauguration day and it's
like this wacky article about like how
amazing it wasn't there like so many
people that it could have attended to
the moon and it was it was really good
in Sharia but the one thing there's
plenty that sounds hilarious so
hilarious all 600 of us write it
together
I'm just glad Obama's gone oh yeah how
about that what the people look even was
great about the 600 women marching it
was all income i mr obama exactly they
were all in celebration for shrunk yeah
it was a woman's march to support Trump
me like we women support Donald Trump
because you know we love Donald Trump
loves women that's what I've heard
I yeah yeah there's a big fan of the
book he's maybe bad he he gets the
Fivefinger discount
so guys I'm proud of what America has
become yeah yeah totally this is a proud
of this is this is probably the best
time for America I mean people were like
oh man you must be embarrassing to have
this guy's your president I'm like that
the exact opposite of what most people
feel especially in California yeah
especially California actually we're
we're like trunk number two
oh yeah whatever you want to do man who
needs a health care when I got this
pipeline under the wall it's gonna be
great it's awesome
let's just sell off all the National
Park
[ __ ] yeah so the condo on that [ __ ] and
I heard Trump gym paddle the law passed
a law that said anyone at any time can
get an abortion yeah everyone has to the
law even if you're I am the real rejects
is a political channel yeah
gerrymandering you're here to get your
facts right just like the onion all week
all right got most accurate if you're
new to this channel which ain't only
about politics always I'm not going to
do with movies
nothing ever that's not the primary
content subscribe to the real reject
yeah
John has reason to Jerry on Twitter and
Instagram Norma he's a social media
manager of Trump's website
yeah me and Kellyanne do we're like this
John writes all of trumps tweets I do on
Facebook right lash bloom council that's
create so calm slash the real rejects
yeah constantly 100 percent sad hump
fans said love Trump see I have a trump
make America great again testing that's
a beautiful job yeah this is us
embodying what overall in LME Trump
Melania Melania Trump does the pro take
well no John this is over we're all over